what do you do you remember when you
first like uh found out Drake knew who
you were yeah so the first time was
I'm just there chilling in my house
I see someone sends me uh
uh uh DM like yo look at this my phone
starts going crazy says Smiley Drake
comments under one of his boys
um Instagram post that he posted one of
my videos and that was us in the group
also we did like a group song and then
he commented Smiley equals gold and then
at that time I didn't even know what
gold meant right I'm like you're like
why is he call me a girl I'm like you
know what no way this to me and like I
was literally a fan of him like from
before I knew he knew who I was type of
[__] I mean he's Drake yeah no but like
at those times
the hood guys and stuff like weren't
listening like I was still bumping him
like that like you know like we're
listening to Drake there would be like
they were listening yes they were but
they're they were doing silent like yeah
like quietly yeah like you know I was
bumping that [__] so then when that
happened I'm like holy then I asked my
sister she was beside me and then she's
just like she tells me what it means I
know [__] it wait the greatest of all
time so I was I was stunned surprised
and then I just my Instagram started
flooding crazy and then that that was
motivation right there also you know so
but I felt like I manifested that also
well how'd you manifest it because this
always excessively playing his songs
just [__] really feeling his songs
like I feel like I have manifest things
and that was another thing I manifested
what's your favorite album of his
my favorite album it's not I wouldn't
say I was always this song songs and
moments I just became right now
listening to people's full albums I
never used it used to be this the
playlist guy the song yeah like and I
would listen to one song 800 times like
yeah right but not the whole body of
work yeah so I used to be that right now
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so Drake owes me fifty thousand
dollars so if we can get him
why why do you see that what is he
always we made a bet together I I met
him in a place called Harriet's in West
Hollywood oh yeah Harriet he was up at
the Harriet's bar
and me and Freddie Gibbs were chopping
it up with him first time I ever met him
and we get into this basketball
discussion
and he bet me fifty thousand dollars
that the warriors were going to go
further than my sons in the playoffs
and uh we agreed to the BET multiple
Witnesses including Freddie Gibbs uh and
the Suns went to the finals and I can't
get a hold of Drake
but you could get older
holy [__] you have to go see him at the
earlier did you see his uh his
freestyles the one on the radar
freestyle Central C's crazy he's pissed
off is he moving like that I don't know
yo it's like he's got like a battery in
his back so he's throwing a little
sample off the new the new album have
you heard the new album no no I haven't
heard it
um who's on your project
um solo straight solo yeah yeah I like
that yeah yeah just trying to
because for me I want my next hit to
just be by myself
it'll mean more to me you know Smiley
featuring smiley yeah yeah yeah cause I
that would mean a lot to me and then
yeah that's what I'm gonna do I'm a
manifest it you guys will see it and go
play this clip again listen we got to
get you a song with peso Puma man it has
to happen we have to let's do it we
gotta take you to Mexico you gotta do a
tour out there we got to take you to
Tijuana yeah I mean
TJ's a movie you know yeah I'm a fish
shirts happen about his music after this
I was gonna say like uh for you talk to
me about your ad-libs because you have
some great ad-libs okay so at first like
when I first started
what I they laid me for at the beginning
was my ad-libs so I'm like oh I'm an I
live guy yeah all right so now I know I
have to just spice it up on the ad-libs
you know so then
[__] I just
now that I overthink it sometimes they
don't hit the same stuff I try not to
overthink it you know what it's so funny
now nowadays when I record I don't
really care for the ad-libs most of the
songs I've only been do add up somewhere
until I know I'm picking these songs for
a tape and then you go back yeah but
like no I don't before I was
what do you think is your quintessential
signature ad-lib
it has to be like the yeah it's the yeah
huh yeah
but he's like the yeah guys
you know I listened to all the critiques
and I I take it in you know so like now
I try to say that yeah in a different
way about say it the way you're saying
it bro sometimes I try to change it up
because I like to take the critiques you
know I think it's dope about you is you
very original in a world full of
unoriginality yeah so I enjoy it for
sure yeah appreciate the 100 man